le président du conseil d'administration
de la stm philippe schnobb un sûr que
les usagers verront la différence dès
lundi prochain avec par exemple du côté
des autobus
dix mille heures de service de plus or
tous les mardis je vais dans une station
de métro avec une petite équipe ça
s'appelle ligne directe s'est annoncée
dans le journal 24 heures et ça donne
des résultats au delà de nos espérances
il ya peut-être 15 à 20 personnes qui
viennent chaque semaine pour pour nous
rencontrer qui ont des questions des
commentaires et c'est très utile d'avoir
ce ce poule à de la clientèle
directement dans le réseau ça permet de
réfléchir façon plus concrète à ce qu'on
veut faire au cours des dix prochaines
années on est dans cet exercice temps il
faut rédiger le plan stratégique jusqu'à
et pour ça on le fait avec la clientèle
on transporte des gens peuvent pas que
des places et des autobus et des métaux
et déjà à bord donc il faut que nos
idées soient en lien avec ce que la
clientèle souhaite les montréalais eux
depuis quatre ans multiplie les heures
de pointe en retard au travail ou aux
études et ils en ont loin dit on et
entassés comme des bêtes dans l'autobus
c'est insupportable en et entassés et je
prends l'autobus à au deuxième arrêt
après le métro a donc imaginé un peu il
ya plusieurs personnes qui n'arrivent
même pas à le prendre et ses quotidiens
récemment à la télévision de radio
canada
l'amiens sa vie à montréal disait en
avoir assez quotidien c'est devenu
insupportable et c'est un facteur de
stress énorme avant d'aller arrivée au
travail
on est toujours stressé est ce qu'on va
pouvoir prendre notre transport est ce
qu'on va pouvoir arriver à l'heure à
notre travail ça devient vraiment
surtout ces dernières années je vous
dirais les deux dernières années sont
particulièrement difficiles au niveau de
l'autobus mais au métro si vous
remarquez si vous prenez votre auto de
votre métro c'est l'achalandage est
énorme la population s'accroît à
montréal et on dirait que le moyen de
transport ne suis pas ne s'adaptent pas
et sous terre des sardines prennent
aussi place
[Musique]
pour remettre sur les rails le transport
en commun montréalais un méga projet du
jamais vu depuis la construction des
barrages géants du grand nord québécois
dans les années 70 sont donc souri
planche à dessin des autorités la caisse
de dépôt et placement du québec
n'hésitez pas à parler en avril dernier
du projet le plus important des 50
dernières années en transport en commun
à montréal il y aura dans cinq ans en
promettant 24 stations 67 km de rails de
plus soit la même longueur que l'actuel
métro de montréal 5,5 milliards de
dollars système léger sur rail
électrique entièrement automatisée qu'il
sera intégrée au réseau transport
existants fonctionnent en 20 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
au moins cent cinquante mille passagers
l'utilisera chaque jour la promesse est
énorme
selon nous c'est réaliste taxis est ce
que cette exigence
oui cet exigeant est-ce que c'est
ambitieux oui c'est ambitieux je pense
et faut être ambitieux et donc il faut
voir grandes marques aussi bien pdg de
la caisse de dépôt et de placement du
québec a et je pense que c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons décidé de
proposer ce projet parce que nous avons
une vision du développement de montréal
du développement du québec
et donc avec une tel système aux
technologies nous allons japon nous
avons pas juste la caisse mais mémorial
nous avons eu l'occasion devant nous
d'un transfert de transformer notre
ville et donc ça c'est évidemment c'est
fait partie de nos objectifs également
ce projet va agir comme une locomotive
de développement économique
ici à montréal et donc pour le québec
est également et finalement mais c'est
très important
on a toute la question de notre
rendement et de répondre aux besoins de
nos clients autrement dit les québécois
moi j'aimerais bien connaître
la distribution de ce nouvel achalandage
d'où viennent ces gens ou van teese qui
vont à l'aéroport dans le technoparc
c'est leur intérêt en aucun détail à ce
sujet là j'en crois est professeur
titulaire spécialisée en gestion du
transport et de la logistique à hec
montréal
au minimum on devrait avoir des études
sur l'achalandage qui viennent étoffer
un peu ses prévisions on devrait avoir
des grandes lignes sur la rentabilité
la tarification de partage des revenus
des dépenses avec les autres sociétés de
transport
on devrait avoir plus de détails sur
l'aménagement des quais des
stationnements incitatifs le
redéploiement des autobus pour des
circuits d'autobus pour en fait
connecter les usagers avec le réseau rm
donc tous des questions fondamentales
des choses qui devront je présume être
discuté en profondeur avec les dossiers
de transport concernés et ça me semble
un peu bizarre que aujourd'hui près d'un
an près d'alençon à on n'a toujours pas
en fait des demandes réponses à ces
questions
un reportage de radio canada
international